i'm very excited about the game that
we're about to play g'day everyone i'm
alana and i'm australian today i am
playing the artful escape which is a
game made by an australian team out of
melbourne i first played this game in
2017 at pax east and was absolutely
blown away one of the best demos of any
game i've ever had i need to fill this
water bottle up give me a second so i'm
going to be playing the first hour of
this game as a thing that i do that i
call first plays i have not played it
outside of the time that i played it in
2017 where the one guy at the booth in
the indie section of pax had set up
speakers because this game is the most
rocking thing
ever basically it was conceived by the
lead guitarist of a band called the
galvatrons the galvatrons had a record
deal with warner bros right out of uh
college for them i believe university as
we'd call it in australia mate and the
artful escape from what i remember is a
guitarist
on an adventure that's glittery and
insane and as described by galvatron
johnny himself it is david bowie
traveling out of london onto an
interstellar trip
where he found ziggy stardust francis
vendetti who is the main character and
the original title for this game was
originally the artful escape of uh
francis vendetti is based on bob dylan
and it's inspired by wes anderson and
spielberg and a whole bunch of movies
the kickstarter that originally um came
with the game
was unsuccessful but it is now being
published by annapurna who i have to
thank for giving me a code so let's
settle in shall we i'm gonna play the
first hour of this game give you guys my
first hour of impressions
and i'm very excited to dive into this
world very excited that this game is
finally out and i hope that it lives up
to my very grand
expectations
let's do it
you see what i mean you see what i was
saying
very stylish
and i remember it being like extremely
metal
and cool and very musical
all right
see a blonde head boy
he be playing in the fields
and his daddy lifts some up how pleasant
[Music]
yeah beautiful landscapes sparkly like
i was blown away by this game when i
first saw it
i feel like the story is going to be
pretty bonkers i feel like i remember
there being dialogue choices as well
well let's do it
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
cool shoes
to strum a [ __ ] ballad about the toil of
a miner's life hold x i'd love to
[Music]
what's up buddy
play a [ __ ] anthony about the green
acreage of calypso colorado hold x
is he forgetting is that what's
happening
something's wrong bud
i too like to hold an acoustic guitar
inside
oh my
to shred a sci-fi guitar to see hold x i
don't don't mind if i do that's what i'm
talking about
[Music]
beautiful place though
i don't know that we need any escape
mechanisms from this place all right can
i go here
[Music]
hot chicks
oh my your look doesn't match your sound
harsh but fair i get that a lot
excuse me
you dress like a drifter but you sound
like a space opera
i don't know what a drifter is
complete tonal disconnect gives me
anxiety
oh
sorry that was
i'm usually much more serious
i play folk music of course you do you
look like you do she's right she's
absolutely right i mean he does i'm
trying to write for the show
my first show
uh-huh but after a while it feels like
i'm strumming backwards and my mind
wanders away
where too
ooh
planets without names the unfathomable
depths of space mid-nebulous is better
than a sunbeam i like that one it sounds
nicer nebula
suspended in a sunbeam
you seem a little lost kid which is good
thank you appreciate that i find lost
young men are in the business of a
rational and dangerous decision i like a
voice a lot
wouldn't you agree
[Music]
not sure about dangerous but i am
irrational
excellent i need you to accompany me to
the summit on leaf road rich i'm going
to commit a crime crimes
what's the crime
the best kind
what is what the mysterious kind
stealing from the rich
what's the crime
the best kind i really hope she'd
elaborate
who are you who are you i'm violeta i
can assure you there's nothing strange
about me at all
she does seem pretty normal okay
i knew you would well i didn't have a
choice to be fair
but also
hot chicks you know you sometimes you
just gotta do it you just gotta go for
it
[Music]
okay first thing i wanted to do whoa
look at the
the style discrepancies
it's very interesting but i can't walk
up any of this i have to go to the left
i i imagine this whole game is a side
scroller
[Music]
scenic lookout huh
the summit
kids come here to hang out at least and
like a lot of drugs
what do you mean hang out
what kind of hangs
and why wasn't i invited
hush
dude this this his gams
this dude has a good jump power for how
small he is
like ain't no muscle on these legs but
he can jump quite high
oh that's beautiful
[Music]
i would like to go there
also decidedly not australian i will
note neither are the characters are
either i think are you making americans
how dare you
i've been betrayed
[Music]
just like goes to tsushima
it's very pretty
oh this is where she asked me to
escalate her to well i just said escort
very strangely but i didn't really
escort her
was he the crimes
isn't that me
after party for your show
romney's going to move the crowd up here
after the liquor license scratches
the skiffle band is playing
they're quite fossil with their opinions
on skiffle i'll give them a chance they
really love skiffle good for them
i don't know what skipple is they're
quite forceful with their opinions on
skiffle plug into the amp on stage i'll
patch you in
okay
is this your stuff of course not
oh she is mysterious and we love a
mysterious woman
more of that frankly
it does sound like a [ __ ] valid stop
no johnson vendetti clonefolk play the
stuff from the lookout
oh no seriously that's nonsense hey when
it comes to nonsense
i'm one of the greats
cool shoulder pad
i'm very into that
okay oh yes let's whale dude
beautiful
[Music]
um
wait i liked that though
that's a shame
[Music]
can that kind of guitar do that i
genuinely don't oh okay i still disagree
clearly uh i have been learning guitar
but i'm not a guitar player is he
actually playing badly because i think
it sounds dope
[Music]
bonanza oh cool great yeah i knew that
that was intentional i did that in the
gameplay
you want me to come back
what are you taking
nothing
crimes
you can't just steal valves what would
gabe think
wait is this romney's stuff you're
stealing valves from rami yeah so
what
about who's robbie i have many questions
everyone says so punched him in the neck
i know
i'm francis
francis vendetti i know who you are kid
i saw the flyers there's a very tiny
picture of you on it
i never signed off on the flyers
you ever made it to the top
i've been too scared of the tree
a mountain surely they're talking about
a mountain
hey cutie oh my
whoa they meant the tree all right
it is beautiful yeah you could really
kill yourself more
you shred pretty well for a folk singer
thanks
so you're standing in the shadows of
johnson vendetti huh he's my uncle
that must suck
it ain't so bad
it's just that i guess folks think they
know who i am where i should be going
have you considered becoming someone
else entirely
great advice
how do you mean
i might tell you about it someday i
gotta scram stay weird kid hey
why is she talking to him like she's an
old man
if you stay weird kid yeah i've gotta
scram
back to the old people's homes
you know lightmans in calypso in calypso
there's no such place maybe you're not
looking hard enough
all right well guess i'll just stay up
here in this tree
someone else
in time nice to meet you i don't know
that we should take her advice seriously
dude she is not a therapist and multiple
personality disorder is some serious
nonsense
i feel like maybe that's not the finest
advice
to take
i'm very into the style though
i like the dialogue
is that why it's called an artful escape
you escaping being you artfully
makes you think
[Music]
if romney finds out i was up here when
his gear got stolen
well
i'd rather not think about it i'm gonna
book it back to town and forget the
whole all right dog let's roll
oh okay i don't have to yeah you go
unrolling by yourself please
i'm very very into this already i mean i
already was
[Laughter]
but uh
it is coming in hard with the tone
already and you guys still haven't seen
what i've seen you guys still haven't
seen
the um crazy colorful sparkly rock
adventure that this game becomes or at
least did become back when i played it
at pax that would have been a vertical
slice so
lena heady what
um
obviously things change
but yeah it's a side scrolling it was a
side-scrolling platformer
more than anything else
[Music]
i actually didn't read any reviews
because i didn't want to spoil it for
myself but i believe it reviewed really
positively too i think reviews came out
yesterday
[Music]
wow he is a big deal also he kind of
cute
where your uncle at and how old are he
[Music]
his last name can't actually be
galbatron
this does just no way
oh my guess is we're probably listening
to how [ __ ] pretty is this his
uncle's francis
you little bastard come to me my love
goldie
you listen
perhaps a bit
i have a ticket to your recital
probably an album's worth i think when
you're beneath those lights
i might catch a glimpse of my old
friend
hmm i don't know what she means
but i hope she's happy
you know
your uncle
oh is he dead i know goldie i really do
did the uncle die
think this place used to be a watchmaker
undeniably haunted possible hub of
underage drinking
like graphical fidelity is so
interesting like these
oranges apples pears whatever look
terrible but everything around them
looks lovely
very interesting approach
thanks man
hey tao
yo i've never seen so many people in
town
yeah it's horrible you listen to that
record
yeah
i kind of loved it actually now that
surprises me what with you being a
serious folk musician
hmm you haven't heard of lightman's you
ever heard of like that
[Music]
junk sci-fi movie
it's not a movie it's a place
innate in this dead end
i'll catch you later though
curious
this is so pretty dude
calypso is usually much quieter
it's quieter each summer the old folks
say people are here for the anniversary
of my uncle's album
it's kind of like a festival everyone's
pretty excited interesting
is he here
and is he available
that's me i'm the nephew johnson
vendetti festival ends tomorrow night
finale is at the salty seagull where
johnson vendetti's nephew will take the
stage for the first time that's me very
excited francis very excited
you avoiding me son
no romney ah the man whose things got
stolen that's not great i find you very
intimidating
what am i doing francis
you
i have no idea i'm smiling oh
wouldn't have guessed
and when i'm smiling you know i don't
mean nothing shady or untoward
despite the gravity of the words i might
be speaking right
we get a full house tomorrow night my
face is friggin hurting i'm smiling so
much when i say
you will play songs exclusively from the
personal repertoire of you oh that's
harsh
or you will
misplace that's very harsh you can't you
can't do that to a
prodigy
well then i suppose
we have an accord
and make sure you show your face at the
after party damn dog
sometimes i used to have to go to
parties and it seems like a ridiculous
thing to complain about but when you
don't want to and you've had a long work
day and then ign is like hey you need to
come to this party you're an employee
and it's like starts at 9pm and you've
worked all day and you don't want it
it is a bummer
there are worse problems to have
cafe cliche very nice
it looks really cute though i want to go
to this place
i realized i probably should have gone
up but what if explore the video game
hello
[Music]
your show is sold out you know that yeah
that's all the posters um there better
be some skiff on your show vendetti for
your sake i'm still not sure
is that a real time should i know what
that is
jazz with pots and pans watch your mouth
and there
i love him the beatles had skipped
he's coming back what is skiffle hotter
than folk music tell you that for free
maybe i'll find out should i go up no i
feel like i should keep going
i have a dream where i swim up that
waterfall i love this place but it's
killing me it's a sight make no mistake
let's go with the dream it's the most
exciting one
hell yeah dude let's do it i think
i wonder what time period this is set in
did i miss them saying that everybody
certainly seems old timey
dude this place is honestly so beautiful
my gosh not what melbourne looks like
let me tell you i don't want to get
anybody disappointed when they visit
melbourne australia
what have you come as
zombie vendetti
that is important oh you died in a car
accident rough
hell yeah
dude i want to eat that oh this place is
so pretty i'm annoyed
a whole fairy floss shop my gosh
oh hello hey you're johnson vendetti's
kid
niece nephew
it's one of the two 50 50. sure whatever
i saw the flyers free show man
and probably won't check it out though
tight that's cool whatever whatever
don't mean nothing nasty honestly i'm
sure you're a good kid
but
you've got no chance of what johnson
vendetti was a folk mastermind once in a
generation
and genius ain't hereditary kid
well
always nice to get the thoughts of an
industry
i like the writing too i'm pleasantly
surprised
and that i know i liked the gameplay but
i also am into everything else that i
hadn't seen you're leaving
what happened
in cassandra is the lights shop's
disappearing sorry what
i won't put up with it who's got lasers
don't mind all that i'm leaving
i feel like there was a lot to unpack
and while you just said that maybe we
should revisit it for the safety of
everybody else here sandra i'm
devastated
yours is the only shop i bothered to
steal from nice lies lies you can come
visit me down the road in donny brook
here
choose a book
from me to you
sci-fi dribble
just how you dig it
morbid psychedelia the scientist poisons
his towns a water supply to appear to
them as an alien being wings of orion
the king disguises himself as a piece of
overcast sky bellachrome using an
illegal avatar mutant rises through the
i'm gonna go with cyber one
oh my
type
well aren't you gonna thank me thanks
sorry
i think i was having an epiphany well
savor it my friend what i wouldn't give
for a good epiphany do you love an
epiphany i had one of those the other
day
francis
you really i don't think you want to be
actually no never mind i've never heard
of it now run along go practice i'm very
curious
planting page expensive books minimal
security
okay choose your own adventure go [ __ ]
yourself all right i'm not here for
your puns okay
apologize
ridiculous dude
oh my
it's small enough to explore so i just
keep wanting to
oh
oh there is lava foot there is romance
of fortune oh my
um hello francis
the pleasure
oh cool thank you yeah to be quite
quickly very efficient mayor
efficient
[Music]
ready for service big show yes uh yeah
just
rounding off the corners
excellent excellent really the town's
counting on you son what with businesses
i don't know why people aren't here
you're gonna need to explain that to me
that's the one part of this world
building that i am not getting
it too for like 12 years
and a series of unexplainable events
that have no basis in fact whatsoever
i feel like i'm being exploited
and also belittled a lot and there's
like a lot of pressure going on i just
feel like this is a lot to put on one
man and that maybe somebody should
anyone who meets here
hush probably a hub for time travelers
oh
um
i just feel like we're treating this boy
very harshly and that somebody should
maybe be held accountable and
you know just
reconsider mental health you know what
i'm saying just i just feel like he's
being bullied
i get it he's a dorky little dweeb
but that's no excuse that's no excuse
[Music]
oh
hello
uh i'm supposed to tell everyone we got
johnson vendetti's 20th anniversary
release of pines in stock type
5 dollars and 5 cents
sorry
the folk masterpiece the voice of an
american generation
or whatever
12 million copies
okay lucy
cutting records by people pretending to
be someone
else i mean sure
you got captain beefheart
legendary stardust that sounds great oh
hank williams pretended to be character
called luke the drifter hank williams
really
why would he do that
to say stuff he couldn't say is hank
williams
epiphany
i wish my epiphanies were that cool i'm
just like oh
interesting
you okay yeah maybe they look like that
to other people that i just don't know
you know
um lightman's you ever heard of a place
called lightmans a place called
lightnings you want me to check out back
no
thanks
also hot everybody's a bit hot
that's that's that's my take what are
these old-timeys look at you being old
looking at views
as you do my place childhood
[Music]
dude
oh my god i hate you
i hate you
this is your house you
[Music]
i'm upset
i don't support you anymore can i play
with somebody else please
is everyone excited to see does somebody
also love me no this is too much nobody
could have a life this perfect
thanks to youtube appreciate that thank
you oh 100g what's up my name honey
i'm really excited
mom
uh-huh you
don't seem yourself working on it
don't seem
myself
the cuts are really funny the most
elaborate stage persona the world has
ever seen
okay
will you be down for dinner we're
heading into life
is that ron burgundy
the boy you love him
on the tv this is san diego
oh my gosh okay
listen the one thing that makes up for
like
this dude
and his beautiful house and everyone
kind of being hot and also like nice
enough to him
um that you buy it that he could
probably take one of them out on a date
is that this wallpaper is the worst
thing i've ever seen in both rooms and
that must be really hard for him to wake
up
and look at this wallpaper
i'm just saying that can't be a good
time there's just no way
that's my dad and my uncle
well
you know what
i disagree
i'm just gonna propose this to you young
man
your uncle
actually a dad
that's all i'm saying your mom in the
other room
definitely getting it off with your
uncle that's how you look the way that
you do
just putting it out there i felt like
somebody should address it that man is
not your father good day
yeah i bet they were from the beginning
no one asks me about my dad much well
that's because he's not your real dad
and maybe they had a threesome and some
mistakes for me
okay you go
cool
[Music]
it's like gone home
is that kratos
boy
skateboard people believe an alien could
play music
yes
i would
believe that could the radio intercept
intergalactic transmissions also yes ooh
that astronaut poster is cool
damn
[Music]
i should take a put a record on chill
out let's do that
we mankind are just 62 miles away
from the infinite surely you've heard
this before sir our side of a thin film
of atmosphere
lies a tundra beyond the limits of human
comprehension
the universe in all its grandeur its
wonder and desolation
waits mere miles away
the stairway to the great cosmic
symphony
is at our feet
is it happening
am i going to the other video game world
where it sparkles and is rock
oh my
an ufo
i believe they call them
ah
an alien
those are lovely flaps you have there my
friend
look like you walk straight down a mass
effect and went to a beauty salon and
got a makeover
okay yeah you stoked to see francis me
too me too i can't wait everybody's
super pumped about it oh i need my
microphone
what was that face that you had there my
friend
it's okay i'm not actually worried
they'll enter the house and they'll see
the bad wallpaper and they'll be like
now and i'll just leave and everything
will be fine
only bad news knocks this lead
what if it's cute girls
stupid nerd
um
hello friend
you you are fabulous
a bit scary i'm not a huge fan of the
legs
but i keep being told that i can't just
come out and say that to people
that's fair
good evening little b a pleasant climate
here don't you think
beautiful
fragrant what's a fragrant climate you
pretentious ass
what
what are you cape dude i am king francis
van dyke
you found him
i am the hypnogic zom i appear tonight
as a herald
doom
and calamity
the support act on our tour is
indispensable
a replacement is needed and the captain
asked for you by name may i put you up
to this
captain
what captain he calls himself
like
wait lightman
you're from lightman's where is it it's
supposed to be in calypso but i've lived
here my whole life there is no such
place was she also an alien
stem extremely
stupid
what
that never seems like a good idea
also he didn't stand extremely still
that was like maybe
like close to still but not even i
wouldn't even say moderately still
how did you do that
where are my pajamas
does it adhere to your hideous
humanoid arrangement yes and it looks
cool as hell i'm in love with you
why are you giving this to me
this lightman's some kind of exclusive
club is lightman some kind of alien
disco is lightman some kind of theater
restaurant
alien disco is lightman some kind of
alien disco
hold out your hand
humor
yes dude yes
good yes
[Music]
how did
did i do that this rules
you're tuning
into another diamond oh my god don't
stop now lightman is waiting on the
other side
hey wait what does that mean how did you
organize this
what did you do to my wallpaper
it wasn't green in there before
for the record i am just holding x while
running right now
i love that you like an alien comes and
gives you a magical guitar and a cool
suit
and what you do with it is just
some fairy lights
town could
maybe use more fairy lights i think
that's what we're doing
[Music]
and fireworks they truly have it all
multiple light sources oh my god
[Music]
i feel like this isn't necessary but the
completionist in me
or even the little kid in me maybe
really wants me to uh
light it all up
[Music]
i'm just holding x
it truly is lit he always puts it away
when i get on the elevator gotta be
quiet it's you know it's the rules it's
like in japan where you're not allowed
to speak on the phone when you're a
public transport similar vibe in calypso
not allowed to play the guitar
dude
[Music]
for me
[Music]
concerts tomorrow night though right
what am i supposed to have i feel like i
have a fair amount of spare time
[Music]
[Music]
way i did it yay
i was worried that i might have missed
him
is lightman perhaps a darkman
[Music]
why doesn't he have to wear a dorky
ready player one suit
he looks way cooler than me
that's how you make an entrance baby
and don't let no one tell you otherwise
this him
i'm afraid what
uh how how how did you i heard the word
you got the aura baby
is there a crane
oh crane just wheeling my feet through
salty licks
are you
lightman jammer of the glamagon in life
now we ain't got much time i'm about to
star in a performance of colossal scope
and i don't go on without a support you
need me
this is the skinny tonight's opening
slot has become available wait
you want me i'm supposed to be a serious
folk musician oh baby we'll have you
back in time for breakfast
what
no i've got my first show tomorrow i'm
in the midst of an existential crisis i
can't just go running off into the
disagree
look at them night
baby we're going way past the night
we're going on a ride across the dilated
pupils of the cop hell yeah i am so sold
you could give me illicit drugs i'd
become addicted to heroin for you good
sir whatever you want
that'll change you forever i'll do it
change me
forever
let me give you the first lesson free
this is the musical key
i mean why it's an x that's a b
[Music]
oh
you're all over it
interesting
now repeat after me okay
rhythm game
[Music]
bah
[Music]
oh i pressed the wrong button
i apologize
[Music]
did i ruin everything i'm really sorry
you seem disappointed
do you still need me to do heroin
because i will
just say the word
i'll do it now copy my notes
[Music]
this is like very fun actually
[Music]
hell yeah dude
this is the coolest i've ever felt in my
entire life
and i'm playing as this door
[Music]
okay look my guitar is cooler but
everything else about him is cool
did we get the wallpaper designs from
his socks
it answered itself
what do you think zom
he'll be dead
harsh
but potentially fair
excellent
follow me
i'm down i'm so down this town is
beautiful and
i'm upset by everybody leaving it for
some reason but also i'm so down
it looks like montmartre
in
paris wait
this isn't here
this isn't a thing
this is an empty warehouse young blood
the stuff behind this door is gonna blow
your mind
let's go i'm ready let's roll
[Music]
stay hydrated
okay
luxury packages
lemons the cosmic extraordinary ask
about your luxury our luxury packages oh
i see i didn't read it that way i i read
it as though it was like a mail room
and that they just have like really cool
mail
this is so cool
i have never heard of any of these
places i want to go to cantalope
this looks like the place where harry
potter goes to
undy sorry spoilers harry potter
francis one little admonition
you need to be cleared with legal
obvious but obviously yeah image right
sync narrative licensing insurance
posthumous royalty is a spectrum
signature you know all pretty standard
is it the
this is not very metal
no
oh no
no no no no no
this seems like a bad time
you get all that
i said i'd do heroin for him signing a
contract i didn't read seems to be about
the same
not one bit voice signature accepted
oh my
did i just get screwed by my two best
friends in the hall well
oh
no guess i'll jump
how could this fit beneath calypso it's
impossible
i mean it's in like a dream world or
something i think my man
but either way i'm very into it
this is like
not a terribly dissimilar gameplay style
to um little nightmares
but complete opposite in tone
it's like you took side scrolling
platformy puzzly
video games and you just went to
completely different directions
i'm really getting harry potter vibes
to pass this sign is to french kiss
death pass this sign is to french kiss i
already said that that's a
striking let's do it
i will french kiss death
oh no is this part returned into silent
hill pt i don't love that
are we gonna french kiss death start one
day unfortunately but you see that door
that's the end of everything you've ever
known
beyond that door
lies the cosmic extraordinary what does
that mean oh man that's the great matter
between the looms of the universe the
outside of reality often described as
the in between us
um
i don't like any of these go with you
can't be serious you
can't be serious
oh you're right you're right about that
you can't be not out here could lose
what's left of your marbles what does it
look like
the cosmic extraordinary oh maybe it
looks different to everyone to me
it's a golden staircase woven lightly
not you
i hope it's like some kind of aquatic
i would like a sea creature please
i'm ready
let's roll let's rock
it would make sense for him that it was
out of space but i was always like such
a fan of that imagery and child of eden
of the space whale that that's what my
brain went straight to
i think it was a space whale
been a while since i played that game
good rhythm game if you were wondering
and haven't played it shalavid
not to be confused a child of what
which is also a very good game but much
more fantasy than child beating
and that's my video game commentary for
the day thank you
can't help myself
impossible
goku
there's a lot of that out here my man
wait where are you going this is the
video game i more distinctly remember
very pretty but in a very different way
to the previous areas prettiness you're
on your own okay
everyone takes their own road across the
cosmic extreme let's go
you're looking for the lung
the cosmic love thank you what's that
it's home baby it's home
[Music]
let's do it
[Music]
i don't even know if you can die in this
game i don't did i need to
do platforming there at all i'm not sure
having just played jedi fallen order the
other day this is uh
i feel like i'm doing a lot of video
game sliding lately and i'm lying with
it
i do need to platform look at us go
this is so cool
what the hell
oh my god i love it
[Music]
he's like the one in my room
[Music]
oh felt like i almost failed that ooh
shiny
are you tracing those rays
sound you better
[Music]
oh that's kind of scary
[Music]
it became a smash bros level
[Music]
this is so cool
i don't know if i've mentioned that yet
what
that's definitely my wallpaper if it
isn't a fluffy little piece of space
thank you you have too many hands and i
don't love that
i've got a strange sound to you
whoa
i'm a wonder make no mistake are you
gone
darling
you know i didn't see her once from a
distance what was it oh that's lena
heady
she was playing bamboo
no way
all the greats are obsessed with pinball
hey i've known a couple of people in my
life who were needlessly obsessed with
pinball
and they were all actually pretty great
the only reason we created the universe
out here
i'm dabbling with the idea of becoming
someone else
this is like if douglas adams books were
a video game which i believe one of them
has been adapted but this the tone
my name is so correct
is something
i don't want to take with me
in this place you are the name of names
but choose wisely
names can get carried away
what
how do you mean they wander off begin to
breathe
before you know it there are books and
banners
scrawling themselves over manifestos a
name once weightless
suddenly burdened with the weight of
them
that ain't some
real talk
what will you name yourself
oh
oh no
friendly cruel elegant intelligent
whimsical i like whimsical as a word the
whimsical
i don't want to go with like alana oh
this is so much pressure
listen i'm gonna do this
because it's what i do in every video
game and i like
the idea that
my boy k owen
goes on adventures everywhere that's
what i name every character i can in any
rpg usually i can change the way that he
looks but it's he's been with me for
years
okay i
went that's me
and where are you headed
the cosmic yes sorry i forgot that
already i was gonna be like the cosmic
eye
really you're touring with lightning
well if you say so i am here
lena heady thank you for asking
dude
are you taking me there
with one of your eyes somehow
what in the heck
okay
all right
if you say so
yep cool great yep that checks out
hello my friend you've returned
what happened where am i you're aboard
the
vessel across the extraordinary
what does that mean francis
does your species gather in caravans of
aimless
cacophonies
debauchery
yes
cruise ships
you mean like a cruise ship
that sounds familiar
why don't you have an explorer
feel things out may i offer some advice
please i'm very confused
okay don't lose your hand not that
helpful
i'll keep that in mind
i maintain not that helpful ah i can't
shred anymore
i used to be able to press extra shred
what the heck
this is so far out what's up there lad
i'm just trying to keep my head
a sensible thing
rather important one said i'm in love
with this this is
like next level no way
there's a whole damn feeder in here
what the hell
what do you think they talk about
oh
where to
cool
i'm good though thank you
oh i do need to play before him don't i
must be performing here
isn't that why i came here you look like
you should be spoken to okay never mind
disregard sorry
this is where we're playing all right
that seems chill i feel like i'm fit for
that
i know i don't necessarily have to walk
through i probably could have used the
fast travel but did these guys walk in
whichever direction i walk and they do
little toilet brushes of
hit
with
legs
oh my gosh
okay
let's see what's happening out here
it's like some far out hendrix album
cover
no okay then i'm not sure what i'm
supposed to do
let's find out shall we
supposed to do something at the theater
was it somebody i'm supposed to talk to
maybe i need to use the map
incredible because i can't walk no i can
only walk left and right visual
okay
mapman
all right
um
let's go to
the mezzanine i see it is levels i
thought it would take me to either side
of this map
gotcha okay okay okay
cool hello
wait
how old are you
i exist outside the realm of age
not here yet look if it's glam glam
juice you want try downstairs hush
i don't know how old he is either but i
assume
18.
do they play by american rules like i
don't know
you're like an intelligence from another
world
i can only surmise you're enraptured
with a sense of wonderment majesty
as certain
i guess so what do you do here
you work on the lawn i am lightman's
first mate
i see to his affairs
what impossible things have you acquired
did you walk through the austrian opera
oh house i did run through that yes
there's so many in vns
easy to dash away with one i left a
paper mache replica in its place
okay i must explored this floor
they're back
my little toilet brush with feet friends
oh my
very cute okay
she's here he's never played a show he's
never even left colorado
you're gonna fry his brain
i think there's a little magic in him
there has to be
thanks man
he thought he was a folk musician this
afternoon where are you sending him
the healer drums oh of course the
heliotrons you are pathetic sorry what's
the heliotrons ah francis i knew you'd
probably make it the heliotrons well
it's somewhat of a monument to me
the whimsical beginnings of my 51
universal tour it's the tour where i
would successfully jam with the glamour
con wow
what's a glamour gone this is bogus mark
seriously he's gonna get vaporized my
name is mark
recalibrate holograms for the kid
this is on you
i prefer not to die and she really
murders my vibe
now curtains are approaching any
questions i'm ready
eh
what kind don't know if there is an
earthly comparison young blood when
creatures buy a ticket to the cosmic
lung they're guaranteed a spectacle of
unique entertainment and that's us well
it ain't you yet we venture out into
wild shred on the edge of cliffslide and
the amphitheaters raise the foundations
of reality of course that's that was
going to be what i was going to guess
but i'm glad you cleaned it up for i had
to then it's all broadcast into the
theater live baby live
live
cool
is there anything else
oh i see i probably like go to different
planets or something
to play and then it's broadcast is back
here
dude
oh my gosh so i feel like based on the
time i should leave it here even though
i feel like i could continue playing
this
probably until finishing it it is
absolutely beautiful and fabulous and
i'm a huge fan um
damn very very very cool i hope you guys
enjoyed
my first hour having fun with the artful
escape here huge thanks to annapurna for
the code and i will see you all next
time bye
i waved my own hair sometimes
it do be like that